we have a slightly involved application
left to do about power plant choice
which takes into account the actual
problem is more complicated than what we
we got the tools to do today but it'll
illustrate a few of the things that that
we we did in particular simultaneous
equations and also use of the
exponential function and that should
take us about 20 minutes and then we
will be done I will not I debated
whether to start you on calculus tonight
but I think that it's the first evening
some people say are saying no and so
maybe it will start on calculus as
planned on on Thursday but we'll do this
this is actually not as as complicated
as it sounds and it's very I like this
example because it is very much about it
is very much a problem that often people
in this field have to deal with okay now
so this is a very common problem okay
and I've simplified it heavily here you
have to choose between a coal power
plant or a gas turbine okay the general
the main characteristic difference
between the two is that a coal plant
requires much more capital investment a
gas turbine is very quick to put up and
it doesn't it doesn't require any cattle
catalysts to try to reduce the sulfur
emissions you know it's not so dirty
it's
the plants are quite modular so capital
costs for a gas turbine is much lower
per megawatt of capacity on the other
hand a coal plant as much lower
operating costs much lower costs per
hour of running and per kilowatt-hour
produced okay so which should you use
well the answer is not obvious if you
are going to use it very little then you
don't care so much about the operating
costs that is the variable cost so
you're probably going to go with which
technology the gas turbine right if
you're going to use it a lot if you're
going to use it all the time then you're
going to care about the operating costs
the variable costs so you you're
probably going to go with the coal plant
okay the exact same problem comes up
with you know fuel-efficient cars versus
gas guzzlers right if you if you drive
if you drive long distances to commute
it pays to have a highly efficient car
but if all you use your car for is the
summer we can jaunt to the Berkshires or
something then you know you might get a
67 Mustang yes
it's sorry exhale Eric oh yeah so that's
a very good question they are not in in
these variable costs obviously so if
permits were required which they are in
Europe but not in the US then the
operating costs of the coal plant would
be higher and the operating costs of the
gas turbine would look relatively
cheaper or nuclear for example would
look even cheaper okay and sorry no no
they would be variable costs because
they would be associated with the total
amount o with the emissions generated
based on usage okay but there are also
ways to convert variable costs into
fixed costs based on expected usage and
so on and we spend some time talking
about that in my class in the economics
class and also in professor Macomber
ease class oh sorry not in professor
Michael Morey's class but in the he does
talk about it too oh ok okay so he talks
about it too and also professor bloom
garden has a has a class on carbon
markets in particular ok now ok so this
suppose that the overnight cost of
building the coal power plant and the
gas turbine are given below so what's
the overnight cost anybody here with a
background in energy ok overnight cost
is the cost is the present value of
building of the present value of all the
can
struction costs as their incurred over
the construction period if you had to
make the plant come up overnight how
much money would you have to spend see a
gas turbine takes three months to put up
a coal plant takes a year so if I was
simply to add up all the construction
costs that I spend over the course of a
year and compare it to all the added
construction costs spent over the course
of three months then I would be
comparing apples to oranges especially
if interest rates were significant right
now of course interest rates are very
low but the appropriate interest rate it
turns out for this sort of problem is
not so much the risk-free rate which
right now is very low but a risky rate
which is generally significantly higher
and for these kinds of problems for
these kinds of investments is
substantial so so the overnight cost I
think I gave you the definition here
cost of the construction project if no
interest was incurred during
construction and as if the project was
completed overnight of course that's not
reality so what do to compute overnight
cost you take the present value of all
cash flows during construction it allows
you to compare construction costs across
technologies which have very different
time horizons construction periods okay
so here here the overnight costs and
those costs are expressed per kilowatt
of capacity okay so this is capacity not
electricity flow okay so this means that
if you if you built a megawatt power
plant that would be a very small power
plant right then you would
and a million dollars a million and
fifty thousand to build that okay and
you would spend 350,000 to build the gas
tube okay now so overnight costs you can
think of as the instantaneous capital
investment now what I'd like to do is to
convert that overnight cost into units
which are the same as the variable cost
okay the overnight cost is what I pay to
put a power plant up overnight now that
power plant has a useful life so it's
going to provide me with electricity /
its useful life and the value of that
electricity is going to depend on the
interest rate as well as other factors
which I've simplified out of this
analysis variable cost on the other hand
is the cost that I spend to generate one
kilowatt-hour of electricity at a point
in time so variable cost is usually
expressed in dollars per kilowatt hour
or dollars per kilowatt year okay so
dollars per kilowatt generated in a unit
of time okay so I've got to convert my
overnight cost which is just dollars per
kilowatt into the same units as variable
costs okay so the way to do that just
think about it conceptually overnight
cost is like paying an upfront purchase
price for your home and variable costs
is like the rent that you save by owning
your home ok so the overnight cost is a
stock and the variable cost is a flow
okay so this is a distinction you want
to keep in mind yes yeah so so in order
to do that translation I've given you a
formula here and so I want to just talk
a little bit about this formula okay
that's fixed cost expressed in dollars
per kilowatt year and how do I get that
in the numerator I have and a rate of
return that I could have earned on my
investment remember the overnight cost
is like my investment the purchase price
for my home the interest rate or the
discount rate times that overnight cost
gives me an approximate annual flow of
benefits that I received from that
investment ok so if instead of buying my
house I had put it in the in the stock
market maybe not that's a bad example if
I had put it in Treasury bonds or
something then I would have earned some
return and that this quantity is going
to be related not exactly the same
because interest rates change and so on
but will be related orders of magnitude
to that annual benefit okay
that's yes that's like my annual
opportunity cost exactly right now below
here i have a quantity which tries to
discount this in such a way that it that
it takes into account that i will
receive our x OC in the first year and
then our x OC in the second year but
when i receive our x OC in the second
year it will not be worth as much to me
as receiving it in the first year
generally built into this is the notion
that dollars in future are worth less to
me today than dollars today okay and
dollars further out into the future a
word even less than dollars less further
out okay when so what you could in
effect do is you could take our x OC let
me actually give you a sense of where
this formula comes from
you could take our times Oh see this is
what I get in the first year as saved
rent or as the return on my investment
plus our x OC in the second year but
discounted back by something it turns
out that what you would discount it by
is 1 plus R okay so if the interest rate
is ten percent you divide this by 1.1 to
get its value today of course if you've
seen present value calculations this
will be familiar to you and in the next
year you would do that divided by 1 plus
R squared and so on okay and you'd have
a series for a power plant with a finite
useful life you have a finite number of
terms here okay you might for other
things you might have an infinite number
of terms okay but it turns out and I'll
show you this in some other class it
turns out that this ends up being
approximately equal to that that is this
wholesome ends up being approximately
equal to that okay this is and if you
remember a summing infinite series in
college or in high school then you'll
you'll recall that the shape of this
formula anywhere right okay don't worry
if that was meaningless okay just that
last part not the whole two hours
okay okay so so so okay so all i did was
i I summed these values to get me the
fixed cost but converted into annual
units okay so when i do that so for the
coal plant I can take 1050 so i put in
1050 here and i do an example here where
the interest rate is ten percent
generally in these formulas the interest
rate is always entered as a decimal
between zero and one so ten percent will
be point one okay if you put in the
number ten you'll get results that don't
make sense so that's that's a good way
to remember whether you did it right or
not and t here is 40 for the coal plant
and 20 this is in years for the gas okay
so when you plug T equals 40 and r
equals point 1 and the 1050 into this
formula then you get the fixed costs for
the coal plant as a hundred and seven
dollars per kilowatt year okay so that
means that to produce one kilowatt
consistently over the course of the year
so to produce one kilowatt every minute
for however many minutes there are in
the year you would need to spend in
fixed costs a hundred and seven dollars
and in effect you need to spend a
hundred and seven dollars on average
every year in present value terms for 40
years so what that does is it translates
your initial investment of 1,050 into a
levelized fixed cost a manual level eyes
fixed cost if you read analyses of wind
power versus nuclear power you'll see
the term levelized costs come up often
okay so this is what levelized cost is
taking an expenditure that occurs in a
short period of time like the purchase
price or the investment costs and you
know that its benefits will be received
over a long period of time but it will
not be received in equal amounts every
year you level eyes it to say what the
average level would be if you were to
receive the benefits equally every year
okay so that's the levelized cost fixed
costs for the coal plant and that's that
for the gas turbine okay now suppose I
give you the variable costs and these
are these are numbers from some eia
report and that is that's eighty-seven
dollars per kilowatt year okay that's
that's about ten dollars per kilowatt
hour okay there are eight thousand seven
hundred and sixty hours in the year okay
you can see that the gas turbine has a
much higher variable cost than the coal
plant okay not excluding the cost of
permits not including the cost of the
permits ok so now yes
yes yes of course yes sorry I skipped a
step
okay so that's the equation right FC
equal to our OC over 1 minus e to the
minus RT okay so for the coal plant for
the coal plant t is equal to 40 and r is
equal to 0 point 1 so FC for the coal
plant is 0 point 1 times the overnight
cost which was 1050 over 1 minus e
remember e is a constant approximately
equal to two point seven one raised to
the power minus RT so that's going to be
point 1 x 40 okay so you will need
you'll need a calculator that has e in
it and when you calculate this out you
should get 10 696 okay
or you can do it in Excel okay okay and
this i just gave you okay this was not
computed okay now but what's but why why
why is this so now that you've gotten to
this stage you can do some simultaneous
equations okay linear simultaneous
equations because I had said that I had
said that the choice of generating
technology depends on how much how
frequently you expect to use the
technology right and our intuition was
that if I'm going to run the plant one
hundred percent of the time chances are
i'm going to pick the coal plant with
the lower variable cost right so you
want to know in answering which plant to
choose your answer surely has to depend
on how frequently you're going to use it
right so all of this all of this is in
terms of kilowatts per year okay so i
can define a variable which is commonly
used in electricity economics called the
capacity factor which is the percentage
of time that the plant is going to be up
and running and generally plants are not
up and running hundred percent of the
time they have maintenance schedules
they may be producing sorry electricity
at a time they they they may be shut
down when
actually in the middle of night winter
and still not quite so and it turns out
the coal plants entered one around
seventy-five percent of the time and gas
turbines can run around twenty percent
and you'll see there's a reason for that
is of course related to the variable and
fixed costs okay so what we're going to
do is ok so if there if so let's go
through this intuition here for a second
if the power line is run on the Senate
of time then how much revenue do you
need to break even or what will be your
total cost of operation it's going to be
your fixed cost plus your variable cost
because this is your fixed cost for all
kilowatts produced in the year so
variable cost for all kilowatts produced
in the year for 8760 hours so if you
were running a hundred percent of the
time you could simply take for the coal
plant 106 96 plus 8760 and you'd get a
number something like 195 per kilowatt
and that's how much your total cost
would be and you take 40 plus 306 if
you're running the gas turbine all the
time and you get a number like 346 and
that be your total cost of operation in
the gas plant right so obviously if you
were running at one hundred percent at a
time 190 is less than 346 so you'd go
with the coal plant but generating
plants are designed for various type
various demand profiles for example a
gas plant is much faster to turn on and
turn off right so you use a gas plant
part of the time you use it generally to
satisfy peak demand
between 1pm and 7pm in the summertime
when everybody runs their
air-conditioned okay so that's why gas
plants run twenty percent of the time
but so so we we want to know which is
the cheaper technology for a particular
given capacity factor so let's define
the variable CF as the capacity factor
and we define it as the proportion of
time the plant has run so it's going to
be a number between 0 and 1 okay and
then I know that then I can draw a
linear function I can draw a linear
equation that tells me the annual
revenue requirement or the break-even
revenue as a function of the capacity
factor for the coal plant that's going
to be equal to the fixed cost to run the
plant for a whole year regardless of how
much I run it plus the variable cost
times the capacity factor if that's
equal to 1 that means that I'm running
it 100 percent of the time but if it's
less than one if it's point one then
I'll only incur ten percent of this okay
and so and similarly for the gas turbine
fixed cost plus the variable cost times
the capacity factor the capacity factors
equal to one then I simply get 30 6 plus
40 okay well these are just linear
equations like the ones you've seen
right this is y equals B plus MX CF is
equal to X
these equations are called screening
curves eula you probably may even have
come across screening curves if you have
heard discussions about wind power
versus nuclear and so on okay so the
question is that what capacity factor is
the gas turbine the cheaper choice okay
well I have screening curves for the gas
turbine and the coal plant and here i
can put the capacity factor on the x
axis and this I could put here I would
call this the break-even revenue or it's
also known as the annual revenue
requirement arr
okay and so for the coal plant I would
start off at 10 696 and I'm going to
rise and is my rise going to be steep or
shallow relative to the gas turbine
shallow right it has a lower slope than
the gas turbine the gas turbine starts
out at forty dollars and forty-eight
cents but it has a quite steep ascent
okay so that will go like will look like
this so this is the gas turbine and this
is the coal plant okay so you can see
and this is really only defined for a
capacity factor up to one right so from
0 to 1 you can see that at a capacity
factor of 1 it should be the case that
the gas turbine is more expensive that
is its break-even revenue or its total
cost is higher than the coal plant okay
so when you plot those two equations out
this is what it looks like these are the
screening curves hey the gas turbine is
green because it's supposedly marginally
cleaner than the Copeland okay okay yes
like so for example if let's say we had
some version of waxman-markey pause and
there is a cost associated with emitting
so you can translate the price if you
give me the carbon market price if it
trades or if there's a tax it's a
natural statutory number let's say that
tax is twenty dollars per ton of carbon
well for the coal plant I know how many
kilowatts are generated whose by-product
is one ton of carbon right so twenty
dollars is going to have to be
translated into a per kilowatt cost and
let's say that that / killer what cost
is ten dollars then I would add to this
slope I would add that ten dollars so up
here so instead of 8750 would be 9760 so
the slope would become steeper okay so
policy would have the impact of making
this line steeper it wouldn't change the
intercept it would make it steeper and
it's possible it's possible of not so
much with gas turbines but if you had
nuclear or solar solar is not really
industrial scale maybe wind it's
possible that it might bring the this
slope down because of the way that those
permits are issued in advance usually 40
cost so it's like a subsidy that's
provided to the power generators and so
in theory the
um the nuclear power producers who
obviously are backing this will get a
huge windfall and the potential benefits
that they get from it should be
amortized over each mega what they
produce so the nuclear power plants
slope would be brought down by a permit
price so would it would look more
competitive the problem with nucleus it
doesn't look like this nucleus starts up
here because it has a very high fixed
cost and then it's relatively flat so
actually with what happens with nuclear
is if you add a carbon price since they
get paid for not generating the carbon
nuclear looks like this okay which is
the reason that the nuclear power
companies were major supporters of that
process sorry cap and trade all the tax
either one yes
right so let's yeah so let I think I I
was i I was a little quick in explaining
that this graph is drawn for the
capacity factor as a variable where if
this is saying that if the capacity
factor was a hundred percent then CF
would be equal to 1 so this is how much
the the coal plant would cost me this
how much the gas turbine would cost so
because coal plants a jet well because
so in demand situations where say demand
is quite varied if you look at the peak
to trough electricity demand it's for a
city is in in the orders of magnitude of
10 to 15 times ok so what so that what
that means is the capacity factor if you
were building power plants to meet a
hundred percent of peak capacity there'd
be times when you were only running a
ten percent capacity right so you can't
have the same technology to meet that
entire profile of demand so you because
of the fixed and variable costs here if
you think that your power plant is going
to run seventy percent of the time you
should pick a coal plant if you think
it's going to run only twenty percent of
the time you should pick the gas turbine
yes so suppose for example that you you
why do you need to build a new plant
presumably there's some shortage of
generated electricity now you have to
determine what the size of your new
plant is going to be relative to your
shortage now what is that shortage that
shortage is not one number clearly
it is very high at peak periods and low
at off-peak periods okay so there's a
range of demand that you need to meet
now if you're if you are able to meet
that peak shortfall with this new plant
that you're going to build then you know
that it's going to run at the peak
period but it's probably not going to
run at the off-peak period so that means
this is a plant that you're going to put
on but it's not going to run seventy
percent of the time it's only going to
run twenty percent of the time so you
would want to make a gas turbine but if
on the other hand you have you know so
that's that would be a situation like
building a peak plant in Long Island
City to meet summertime demand but let's
say that you're in India where routinely
there is load shedding then your power
shortage is not I mean certainly you
have a power shortage of peak periods
but you probably even have a power
shortage at base load so the new plant
that you bring online is going to run
seventy percent of the time it's got to
feed power both at off peak and peak
periods so then you're going to build a
coal plant so you know that's this is
basically a method of choosing the
cheapest way the cheapest generating
technology not taking into account
externalities if the prices exist for
the externalities you would you would be
able to take it account take account of
it in this framework okay so so you
could so this is of course just a system
of two linear equations and just like
those
pull linear equations you saw before
there is a point where they intersect so
you know and that point happens to be 0
point 304 so you know that if your
capacity factor is less than that you're
going to go with gas if it's more than
that you're going to go with coal and in
reality you would have many different
screening curves for every different
technology and you'll see that they
intersect in different places okay and
part of policy is how do these things
move around when you put in a permit
price or when you change the interest
rate which will have a huge impact on
this too yes yeah that's factored in
already so you see that's that's exactly
what you were doing so that's a very
good question that's what you were doing
when you made this calculation you were
taking the levelized animal fixed cost
so you are saying yes it's this gas
turbine only lives for 20 years but I've
converted that into an annual cost so
that the variable and fixed costs are in
the same units ok so these these costs
are per year costs ok that's it any
questions ok thank you
okay i'll see you tomorrow at
orientation